for those who enjoyed an officer in the
gentlemen and the large discipline
here's a novelty tonight David Keith out
of uniform with him is the fellow cadet
from an officer and a gentleman
he finally made it over the wall Lisa L
Baca
our generation takes many things for
granted
among them the motion picture soundtrack
there was a time when the only sound you
heard in a movie theater was a piano
player of course that was before our
scientists perfected the noise a candy
wrapper without the soundtrack we never
would have heard Camille's cough mrs.
Miniver Stears Pilates laugh or ring Tim
Tims bark the Academy salutes this
year's nominees for best achievement
sound they are Milan boar
Trevor pike and Mike Lamarr for dust
boat Robert Knudsen Robert glass Don
Girolamo and Jean consumation for ET the
extra-terrestrial
Jerry Humphreys Robin O'Donoghue
Jonathan Bates and Simon K for Gandhi
Arthur Piazza go see less free Holt's
dick
Alexander unless Lazar wits for Tootsie
Michael Minkler Bob Ming clearly Minkler
the Minkler gang and their buddy Jim
Marui for trying Lisa will you sound out
the winner and the winner is the winners
are Robert Knudsen Robert
accepting the sound award for
Robert come in sir
I always changed an evasive production
mix are on the et and nothing has ever
done alone it's always a team effort I'd
like to thank my guys my team Rob Bruce
my boom operator Steve Payne my third
man and my lady Don for having the faith
and thank you very much saying thank you
seems a little inadequate tonight but
that's all I have to offer tonight as
thank you to Steven Spielberg for all
his help and there's patience and the
guidance that helped get us all up here
tonight also
Kathy Kennedy the producer Carol
Littleton Chuck Campbell who really made
it all go together and Jenny and Mark
Sullivan back in Columbia South Carolina
who's waited up and hope to see their
granddaddy tonight time to go to bed
kids